c'est une histoire à laquelle on
s'intéresse depuis la semaine dernière
le combat humaniste de stéphane watelet
boulanger à besançon i le 3 janvier
dernier a décidé d'entamer une grève de
la faim pour s'opposer à l'expulsion de
là il faut des traoré son apprenti en
attente de régularisation il faut bouger
enfin c'est si on fait pas quelque chose
bah c'est un plus qui repart à la mer
quoi des fans ravva clé était mercredi
dernier sur notre plateau pour nous
raconter son combat
mais alors que le boulanger continuer sa
grève de la faim avec toujours autant de
détermination cyril nous apprenait mardi
en direct que l'homme est au plus mal et
aurait été victime d'un malaise ça
commence à vous inquiéter plus en plus
ou qu'on le dit et si cette nouvelle
était inquiétante elle semble signer la
fin d'un combat acharné
en effet aujourd'hui stéphane raclée a
finalement été entendu et nous avons une
très bonne nouvelle à vous annoncer ce
soir sur le plateau de thé pnd qu'on est
content et qu'est ce qu'on y envoie
relais et de l'aï d'ailleurs dit l'aïe
est de voir stéphane stéphane et l'ail
merci d'être là stéphane mahé manger
quand même non pas encore quoi mes
frères moite étonné quand tu pourrais je
termine frère à la ville aménage il
serait arrivé pouces mais que la fin du
ramadan vers 3 heures du matin et on lui
a ramené veut pas manger métier tu as
hâte en fait j'ai compris tu vas être
beau gosse juste eu peur semble stéphane
tu dois être heureux
oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors donc
tu te sens soulagé ça faisait 15 juin
jour qu'on était en grève de la faim
quelque chose doit manger
stéphane alors à quoi tu roules tu as
aimé la france entière aujourd'hui je te
sentir je te sens soulagé en fait ce
sont même fatigué tu sais tête à lâcher
la pression
et bien c'est bien en fait
comment le combat s'est terminé
aujourd'hui le premier combat s'est
terminé autour dû arrêter un soulagement
extravagant en fait parce que là il est
là mais il est présent en phase et vous
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi
aujourd'hui les panières enfin vous la
bourse
la situation est propre maintenant nous
avons été reçus par là par la préfète de
bozouls en haute saône doubs i et ii le
département d'olt y y il était inscrit
par rapport à 100 foyers et en fait on a
été on a été demandé hier on a été
convoqué et je me suis dit hier bon
toute façon que vaut pas les gens pour
leur dire que non il n'y a pas si c'est
pas possible en fait bas et donc quand
vous avez la provocation vd s'est
procuré jeudi ses traits ça sent bon
mais housse ou bien j'avais et j'avais
certaines peurs ses ou 6 mois ou en
finlande il ya tellement de possibilités
et en fait j'en ai pas dormi évidemment
de la nuit mais en fait pas dormir moins
[Rires]
agréables en fait c'est des situations
qui nous appartiennent pas en fait je
suis pas fait pour ça comme je vous ai
déjà dit je suis pas fait pour moi j'ai
fait pour mon fournil et mon travail
mais des situations comme ça c'est hors
norme pour moi
donc en fait ont été très bien reçus
voilà avec avec une finalité un cas
exceptionnel en fait pour le derby c'est
là là il va pouvoir rester en france
c'est ça ouais donc qu'est ce qui se
passe alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
aujourd'hui ça voilà qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et qu est-ce qui est lui octroie
mais bon on lui octroie
alors oui les mots bien c'est dur mais
un
un droit de rester travailler en france
et dans un mois il réussit à sa carte
d'identité
c'est bien d'arriver à pas le concept
cars 2 est donc d'avoir votre carte
d'identité live vous êtes heureux très
heureux très heureux
stéphane c'est savent ça vous a
énormément touchés ce qu'il a fait oui
ça m'a énormément touché vous êtes
heureux de continuer à travailler avec
lui de paris vous faites un travail
magnifique c'est extrêmement sérieux en
fait je lui avais rien à l'entraînement
quand il est rentré de mon entreprise
lui dis gamin il faut que tu fasses
attention parce qu'on te on va tous
mourir on va cueillir ton travail
il faut voir falloir que tu sommes
meilleurs que les autres je suis tu
travailles beaucoup plus sceptique mais
on savait qu'il y avait les pays au
dessus de sa tête parce que bon à 18 ans
savait très bien qu'il y allait avoir
des problèmes
donc je vais toujours dit tu fais pas
l'idiot tu te bats pas tu es sérieux
jusqu'au bout et en fait ça a été dur et
aussi pour ça en fait le domaine il a
way a jamais bougé d'un oeil dans mon
entreprise et à l'école il
voilà donc lui avec lui avait dit si tu
fais pas le con on y arrivera excusez
moi du terme mais c'est ça c'est la
vérité vraie et en fait ça a été aussi
juger par ce biais là c'est à dire que
c'était un enfant sérieux qui avait
envie de travailler qui avait envie de
faire de faire sa vie correctement
d'avoir voilà bon et bien comment vous
l'avez appris la bonne nouvelle alors on
a été convoqué à la préfecture de 2,2
selon ghazi et vous avez senti sur le
chemin puis nommé pour elle si en nous
qu'on vous avez mangé c'est pas manger
quand il vous dit
quand j'ai été comme un jour de tonnerre
fin mai 11 jours frère moi à la base des
préfectures de bozouls à m'appelle
vivalis au raku ce concert quand on a un
vrai combat en fait si j'ai fait des
régimes parce que je suis un peu
imposant mais en fait c'est sympa en
fait c'est pas un régime c'est une
obligation de 2,2 d'aller jusqu'au bout
et donc j'ai pas du tout fin parce que
le combat n'était et puis je me suis
vous avez eu un petit malaise quand même
à ben oui parce qu'on fait que tu
arrives au travail est à 4 heures du
matin il y avait mais c'est la première
fois
voilà un thomas perrot duval âge je te
fais quelque chose frères voilà tu me
dire bon arrière alors non mais en fait
je savais que l'ago nalité à les
planques parce qu'enfin qui avait
vraiment très faim ce qu'il n'était
jamais arrivé
et en fait j'ai senti ma force diminué
et j'ai fait un malaise dans la voiture
en arrivant de voilà devant le magasin
est à 8 heures du matin et puis bon
après mais je remercie véritablement les
les institutions hospitalières parce
qu'en fait ils ont tellement de travail
en ce moment bien sûr alors voilà oui je
voulais de toute façon arrêté rapidement
parce que je voulais pas recommencer les
embêter tout le monde
voilà je suis quelqu'un de sérieux et
voilà donc mais tous tout se finit
correctement et bien c'est génial non la
wii nommé cette semaine est heureux
évidemment fin il ya très longtemps que
j'ai pas eu autant de plaisir que ça en
fait une aussi bonne nouvelle je voulais
remercier plein de monde si vous
m'élisez c'est comme si vous avez un
[Rires]
ça fait lui non enviable merga c'était à
bouffer en premier lieu à wenzhou
oui merci stéphane parce qu'ils vont
vite vous êtes la seule télévision
tu m'as demandé merci stéphane remercie
vraiment à ça nous fait plaisir la voilà
donc je vous remercie tous en fête
bah oui parce que regards croisés sur
mon problème les affaires et sur les
problèmes de l'aïe
vous êtes à celle télévision voilà donc
un énorme merci je pense que dans ma vie
vu je penserai toujours à vous tous
premièrement système deuxièmement ce
sont les réseaux sociaux alors moi je
vis à vis de la dernière fois qu'un
vieux croûtons et que j'ai vu que ça
sert les réseaux sociaux c'est normal en
fait j'ai des amis delphine et son fils
et sa fille et c'est qu'ils ont fait ce
cette pétition
c'est magnifique ils ont été magnifiques
et en fait ça s'est déroulé tout
doucement ou d'une mèche est en fait me
voilà ça c'est c'était extraordinaire
et en fait de plus en plus en plus il ya
eu du monde et monsieur klaus mann a
facilité les européens
bravo à lui voyez votre passage ici ça
la semaine dernière et raffeisen amis et
je voudrais dire à votre échelle si rim
et appartient pas et aux gens du
gouvernement
j'imagine que ça c'est bon c'est pas en
tout cas l'un portera c'est que c'était
avec des neiges le dénouement soit là et
je voudrais dire un truc et j'aurai moi
si yann barthès et même lui a retweeté
votre passage ne touche pas à mon poste
bravo à lui pour vraiment pour vous
aider voilà et les médias n'ont pas fait
pareil aujourd'hui alors à ses propos de
ce dénouement justement est fabuleux et
c'est ça qui compta et on est mal sur
politique et lui enfin aujourd'hui moi
que je sais que demain ça avait une un
déferlement au magasin oui passerait
forcément du goût de faire de trop
des moyens vous avez déjà une galette
pour vous ça c'est du pain je me suis
dit que patrick cdu part à la
négociation cette année la navigation la
mer si ce n'est pas aussi remercier si
j'ai encore la cpaci voulais remercier
les boulangers de de saint-honoré dont
je fais partie sont ils ont été les
premiers boulangerie à relayer l'info
bravo à eux ensuite
voilà enfin c'est tous les anonymes je
ne connaîtrai jamais donc les personnes
qui ont relayé l'info ça a été
extraordinaire et un tsunami et de
bonheur en fait on m'appelait on dit
mais tu te rends compte à dépasser site
ad enfin moi je ne connais pas tous ces
chiffres en fait je m'en rends pas
compte on fait tous vous avez l'habitude
parce que c'est tout le monde c'est
votre papa non non mais on reste est
simple mais moi j'ai encore faim voilà
ça m'appartient pas en fait tout ça
c'est tellement fort et effectivement
moi je déplore malgré tout que certains
médias eurent de malhonnêteté
intellectuelle de certains médias qui
qui voilà qui n'ont pas voulu parler de
vous ici et de l'action vous avez quand
même mené aussi et je trouve que c'est
dommage parce que si on a besoin
aujourd'hui de deux choses qui nous
soude qui font état qui font corps et et
voilà et ça je trouve que c'est un peu
malhonnête que certains médias mais des
oeillères les boules quiès parce que
voilà quand il s'agit de vous on se
bouche l'année côté quand il s'agit de
moi au tout ça on sait faire des
articles pour dire que je suis méchant
gentil voulez que je vous dise je m'en
fiche totalement détruits sont les faits
majesté sous silence
géraldine vous êtes un amour mais je
suis totalement moi ce qui compte c'est
que stéphane il peut y avoir là il y
avait crié sur et je vais vous dire
franchement l'avis de certains si les
papiers de certains mais j'aurais
peut-être un amour en tout cas pour
chamois mealamu rejetant sur stock c'est
bien parce que dans dans le foot actuel
je sais bien que c'est important de se
tenir les mains moites et demain vous
verrez il y aura des titres de la touche
pas à mon poste cyril hanouna dire
bernard montiel était et est trop bondée
où un truc là mais il y aura jamais de
titre de la grammaire est totalement oui
merci moi il est important c'est
l'arrivée j'avais vu sur une question ce
que vous avez fait formidable alors il
va devoir à faire mais il est sympa
alors il est exemplaire
mais il ya plein de stéphane en france
il ya de cephalon bien sûr bien sûr et
stéphane il aurait pu perdre sa vie je
vous le dis au passage nous l'avait déjà
deux trois jours que vous étiez à de
droit de douala vous avez vous a été
malade dernièrement stéphane non mais la
question après parce que le problème et
c'est à dire que l'intégration par le
travail j'y crois il s'est battu et
s'est mis en danger
mais comment on fait pour les autres
stéphane alors alors écoutez ça c'est un
débat vous alors parler parce qu'on aura
le cadavre exquis les maths et 1h18 ya
eric naulleau qui arrive juste après
pour btp et ça c'est le jeu revient bien
entendu dans btp dès la semaine
prochaine et eric naulleau est
formidable à la tête de cette émission
mais il leur reviendrait eu lieu la
semaine prochaine
et avec eric bien sûr et eric est
formidable vous allez retrouver en
direct dans un vent et la semaine
dernière il a cartonné oui je crée
vraiment la présidence nous appeler ce
après midi quand on était dans le train
avant mais dans ce cas c'est monsieur
macron bâtiment de ses bras droits nous
appeler comme quoi le voilà le président
avait regardé le dossier
voilà c'est génial de l heure elle a
remercié en fait voilà tous ces
politiques les députés qui m'ont appelée
e
merci parce qu'en fait c'est et on est
en train
j'essaye de l'envié de faire une une
proposition de loi avec des députés pour
la prendre soin des gamins que jusqu'à
une intention de double diplôme
[Applaudissements]
maintenant nous en parler tant courir
les laits si ce n'est pas lady lui des
missiles alors les deux et masi souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur